quelle
il était elle c'est le nom du téléfilm
qui était diffusé hier soir sur tf1 et
on peut commencer quand l'histoire
émouvante d'un adolescent transgenres
nommé juju qui malgré les moqueries à
l'école et sa difficulté à convaincre
ses parents de changer de sexe va tout
faire pour effectuer sa transition est
pas un mec simfy hockey un personnage
magnifiquement interprétée par l'actrice
andrea furet elle même tranche d'or est
la mieux placée pour jouer ce rôle tu me
connaître une deuxième fois si la
première chaîne croyait beaucoup en ce
téléfilm qui traitait pour la première
fois de la transidentité les
téléspectateurs n'étaient pourtant que
3,14 millions devant la télévision avec
une part de marché de 15,6 pour cent
merci un score encourageant pourtant le
film n'a pas fait l'unanimité sur les
réseaux sociaux alors comprenez vous que
le film il est elle sur tf1 et orteils
certains téléspectateurs
alors justement nous sommes avec olivia
sympa bonjour j'ai bien dis merci d'être
là vous êtes photographe transgenres et
alice cordier présidente du collectif
nemesis merci à l'iss merci d'être là
tous les deux et on va on va voir des
extraits de ce téléfilm qui a fait
énormément parler et c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu une revue de tweets djoudi qui a été
incroyable le film a fait il y en a qui
ont dit voilà il bat quand je vois les
commentaires sur idéal je me dis qu'il
ya encore des progrès à faire chez
certains ça devient très grave la merci
à tf1 d'avoir proposé ce téléfilm en
prime time y en a qui disent ce film est
une propagande pour sur la première
chaîne de télévision une honte pour le
bien de nos enfants éloignons les de ce
genre de propagande les séries télé pour
éduquer la société vont en fait la
détruire voilà il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont insurgés contre ce téléfilm
mire alors on a pu notamment voir un
extrait force est un des rendez vous
chez le médecin ou les parents d'une
heure se demande encore s'il faut
accepter cette transition regardez alors
les grandes étapes et on n'est pas
obligé toutes les faire c'est
la liberté de chaque patient ce sont le
changement d'apparence et de prénom au
quotidien laprise estrogènes la
mammoplastie la vaginoplastie et le
changement d'état civil c'est beaucoup
d'informations à la fois par les entre
vous documentez vous
au revoir en jeu merci
au revoir
[Musique]
c'était votre enfant vous le feriez
n'essaie pas mon enfant
t il et où
les conseils aujourd'hui fait des
commentaires merci en tout cas au lider
d'être là est-ce qu comment vous avez
trouvé le film moi j'ai trouvé génial
vraiment mais vraiment très très bien
parce que parce qu'on ça permettait en
fait aux spectateurs d'avoir une vraie
empathie pour elle qu'on connaisse ou
pas le sujet on découvrait au fur et à
mesure comme les parents du coup et on
est à partir du moment où on avait envie
qu'elle se fasse accepter par ses
parents par la société par l'école bah
en fait ça permet d'avoir une tolérance
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
disent qu'il ne faut pas montrer ça aux
enfants en fait c'est des gens qui
veulent juste un visibiliser par des
gens qui voudraient c'était les mêmes
qui au moment du mariage pour tous
voulaient surtout pas qu'on montre un
couple d'hommes qui sen qui s'embrassent
a en fait ça fait partie de la société
celle assez présent des enfants
transgenres il y en a plein les enfants
transgenres qui se suicide il y en a
énormément ça fait partie de la réalité
ils ont besoin qu'on les cons les qu'on
les comprenne ils ont besoin qu'on les
soutienne ils ont besoin qu'on soit avec
eux parce que si on n'est pas avec eux
ils vont ouvrir en fait donc maintenant
ça se passe ça va ça se passe bien moi
ça se passe très très bien parce que
j'ai 42 ans mais si j'avais pu voir des
films comme ça quand j'avais 12 ans
j'aurai fait mon vous avez j'aurais rêvé
souffert de certaines situations ou de
certaines remarques non parce que je les
fais beaucoup trop tard en fait parce
que j'ai été lâche pas ce n'est pas de
filmer comme ça allez vous avez fait
quoi racontez nous votre histoire moi
j'ai fait ma transition l'année dernière
fois les dernières l'année dernière
après avoir atteint jusqu'à 40 ans vous
étiez jusqu'à 41 ans ces accords et
après une tentative de suicide où je
suis resté cinq jours dans le coma ou
vous sentiez bien décider de de dire
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] en fait deux ans
que de ce que la société pourrait dire
devant vous sentiez vous sentiez pas
bien dans votre corps pendant 41 ans
très mal ou y ait en fait si j'avais vu
ce film en étant ado j'aurais
transitionner beaucoup plus tôt que
j'aurais gagné plus de 20 vous l'avez
pas fait plus tôt parce que l'art dans
la société parce que les médias ont
énormément
caricaturer la transidentité on nous
montrait comme une espèce de pathologies
graves
horrible passé ce qu'il veut au moins
celle ont pris comme en hyper bien mais
ça parce qu'ils ont été soulagés prouver
ce qu'ils sont ils sont beaucoup mieux
cotés au moins c'était sais je suis un
exemple unique parce que je je j'ai la
chance d'être extrêmement médiatisé sur
les réseaux sociaux et de la forêt était
avant sa est en fait à partir du moment
où j'ai fait cette transition cette
espèce de coming out qui était peut-être
le premier pour une personne en france
en tout cas ce pacioretty zay il ya eu
un amour démentiel de dizaines et
dizaines vous n'étiez pas heureux mais
aujourd'hui vous êtes heureuse amène à
fond vraiment c'est inimaginable vous
l'expliquer à quel point et c'est je me
sens soutenu je m'y attendais pas le
chien quand même
parce que je vois que vous êtes
tellement heureuse j'ai peur que vous
être oublier le chien dans la
soixantaine a trouvé sa pelle elle
s'appelle l'îlot l'îlot battre eh bien
voilà merci enfin cécile faisons donc
effectivement c'est très bien mais il
faut savoir que des toutes les personnes
trans en fait le savent dès dès leur
plus jeune âge en fait quand elles ont
quatre ans cinq ans et en fait elle
n'ose pas comme moi j'ai pas osé pendant
toutes ces années parce qu'on n'avait
pas de modèles comme ça que ce soit dans
l'est dans les médias que ce soit par
l'alors en plus cela c'est une actrice
transgenres sais j'ai loupé sur steam à
une des scènes les plus fortes aussi du
téléfilm c'est quand le père de julien
accepte enfin de signer les papiers pour
sa transition vous allez voir c'est un
passage très très compliqué
tu étais mon fils est allé porter le
moment le transmettre
dirrell je saurai pas non mais changent
la manière que tu comprennes que tu
acceptes on se voit pas
comment ça
je sais pas faire
alors vous à nice ça pour vous c'est
inadmissible sur tf1 en prime time ah
bah moi c'est mes enfants voient ça à la
télé jusqu'à ce la télé en fait
inacceptable de mettre déjà enfin
l'enfant c'est une perte déjà tellement
de construction déjà tellement compliqué
sans parler de l'adolescence qui
s'ensuit et en plus on vous met dans la
tête que vous n'êtes pas dans le bon
sens on
sait très bien ce qu'il ya derrière est
en train de dire toi derrière moi
derrière mais si la grande on l'a connue
mais c'est une propagande de 2 voilà de
certains lobbys qui veulent mettre dans
la tête des enfants qui se sont
peut-être trompés c'est une propagande
aussi pour mettre en avant les droits
d'une minorité et ce à la rigueur c'est
une autre question mais pourquoi les
enfants
et pourtant elle a eu ce mal-être toute
sa vie mais il ya en fait jamais si ce
volet qui se suicide après avoir
transitionner faudrait peut-être qu'on
en parle aussi de cela doit être une
instabilité aussi il ya peut-être eu
énormément non mais j'ai ces gens qui se
suicident parce qu'ils ont transitionner
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont transitionner
ils se suicident parce qu'à tellement de
haine de la société
vient de tomber et mandaté l'association
au royaume uni ou en suède qui font demi
tour justement parce qu'ils étaient dans
un livre de propagande attention je suis
de propagande de justement d'être enfin
trop de faire transiter les enfants qui
se poseraient des questions il se rend
compte de l'impact sousse dans me2
soudan et des gens qui te positionnes
100 % des gens qui transition c'est
justement par rapport à la haine de la
société la haine de la société parce que
les gens ne voient pas ce genre de film
mais si
les supports ce que tu es tu penses que
tf1 n'aurait jamais dû diffuser ce film
au prince
alors je voulais laisser c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle le téléfilm n'a pas
marché du tout non c'est vrai nom vient
en fait et je sais pas pourquoi mais
c'est vrai que ça peut ça peut poser
question parce que j'ai comme ça c'est
non non non non c'est magnifique pour
allécher restée non les gros chiens
production je vous dis la vérité ça fait
deux ans que c'est dans les tiroirs je
vous dis la vérité j'aurai et j'aurais
aimé que ça fasse 6,7 millions hier oui
j'ai été assez déçu du score et même
tout le monde était déçu parce que
c'était une très grosse production pour
tf1 ça fait deux ans que c'est dans les
tiroirs un tf1 hésité à le à le diffuser
et finalement ils ont diffusé hier soir
un jour férié je pense franchement et
moi c'est mon coup de gueule
quelle erreur de diffuser sa famille
quelle erreur de programmation telle
erreur de l'opération lamentable celui
qui a programmé ça un jour un jour férié
comme ça c'est sais pas c'est pas la
bonne programmation puisque je vous dis
c'est vrai qu'un autre chose aurait fait
beaucoup plus on aurait aimé que ce
téléfilm phase 5 6 millions et ils l'ont
été il a été pénalisé je vous dis par la
programmation en jour ce dernier hier
c'était comme un dimanche soir on est
unanime c'est resté comme un dimanche
c'était un jour férié et c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt les grosses productions
voilà très familial qui marche et c'est
vrai que là voilà on aurait mis un jeudi
soir ou un autre soit un autre lundi
soir serait beaucoup mieux marché là je
trouve qu'ils ont un petit peu jeté
voilà le maître lundi soir comme ça un
1er novembre si c'était une connerie
mais oui s'il lui moi lui merci moi je
dis bravo tf1 d'avoir fait ça tente de
faire évoluer un peu les mentalités il
faut savoir qu'il ya quand même à peu
près quinze mille n'y a pas d'étude très
sérieuse là dessus mais une estimation
de 15000 transgenres en france et sa
nuit comme vous l'avez dit madame se
doit les aider un peu et je dis bravo
qu'ils le fassent on va voir infractions
les enfants mais quand
il n'y a pas des durs
je veux dire à des impacts et ça va être
très
méchant c'est ce que serré la
connaissance il ya des dessus du but
n'est pas non plus
fixé existait pas j'ai dit que je vois
bien que m chaleur pour toi d'anguille
et je ne
vous parle pas de l'aimer et structurel
de l'iss ou si c'est la vie alors il ya
une autre scène rien
s'il vous plaît il ya d'autres scènes
marquantes c'est lorsque juge
d'embrasser un garçon au lycée le jeune
homme n'a aucune idée voilà qu'elle a
changé de genre regardez
[Musique]
ça va
immense
alors
oui je trouve ça incroyable mademoiselle
je me suis même plus votre contrat
discorde et j'écris des mois il est en
train de sous-entendre qu'il ya des
enfants qui parce qu'ils ont regardé le
film on dira pierre sagna est bien c'est
qu'on est de changer le regard des
badauds
d'aborder un sujet 40 francs qui était
caché je vois pas où est ce que
j'appelle sur les enfants qui manquent
mais j'insiste sur l'enfance où on se
prend pour un chance quand on a un
animal on se rend pour plein de choses
mais on se prend c'est une période de
chrétien avaient des enseignants et
d'imagination des anciens qu'on ait
besoin de ces quand
j'aurai attendu qu'est le seul à dire
oui s'il vous plaît les autres non ça y
est on en a beaucoup mieux alors men
origins d'abord je vous remercie oui a
livré l'un des quatre titre personnel je
ne suis pas choqué mais à la question
comprenez vous oui je comprends pour
quel motif je pense que ça manquait
d'explication de maisons perspective de
libération mais mon opinion
non mais attendez je parle pas non mais
je ne parle pas du fond ce que vous
dites est magnifique je parle du fait
que ce soir là à cette heure là sur tf1
à une heure de grande écoute pendant les
vacances un jour férié pour moi c'est
pas le bon film
il faut débat il faut qu'ils aient un
débat il faut caussade rami on puisse
discuter mais pour moi ce film c'est un
film militant et les tests m'a très bien
construit jambes et je moi je comprends
que cela ait choqué valérie et
d'ailleurs ça a choqué je vous disais je
ne parle pas de la cause dans olive et
relire juste en fait quand on parle de
de propagande c'est intéressant parce
que ça nous ramène à tout ce qu'on a
entendu au moment du mariage pour tous
quand on disait le fait de voir que
quand deux enfants me voir deux hommes
qui s'embrassent ils vont vouloir
devenir qu'on sait c'est que les héros
viriat de la propagande sur sa peau qui
pose avec par une baignade de propagande
il ya par contre si vous voulez en fait
la lys c'est une invisibilisation répète
une réalité qu existe bien sûr vous
voulez un visibiliser ses enfants qui
exhibe l'invisibilité les personnes
comme moi en disant surtout ne montrez
pas autoriser ces papas et c'est vous
qui intervient 18 en faites ce que vous
voulez entre 0 et 18 c'est le
chat du tout il faut justement pouvoir
leur montrer pouvoir justement les
rendre au tollé rang ne surtout pas
caché ça parce que quand ça quand on le
cache et selanne sacré de la haine
ensuite c'est là où ça crée de
l'incompréhension est votre réaction
elle n'est n'est que par la peur elle n'
est pas vrai mais l'inconnu et d'où ça
vient ça va très bientôt dix ans
populaire c'est pas du boulanger
entendait quand vous entendez halliche
est ce que vous voulez de l'union est ce
que vous voulez c'est le cas pour faire
des beaux jardins castellion évidemment
mais c'est alors voilà ce qui me choque
c'est le mot propagande franchement
c'était courant ici en leurs ventes
madame et pays où les salopards dès
qu'ils sont rongeurs sont déportés là je
peux pas entendre
les enfants un discours excusez moi
c'est épouvantable celui de cesser s'est
passé pas une maladie étrange ancêtres
sont des gens ici sont justes mais qui
sont trop ils sont nous sommes d'accord
une rustine kiné qui n'est pas la bonne
comme un rite aid chose pareille cause
et il n'aurait jamais dans la bonne en
velay a répondu amis quand elle vous
aidera médecin vous a pas fait des
études on le sait que ça existe
également effectivement on sait pas
des contes de fées moderne
vous dites 18 ans entre cédé il ya des
enfants à 4-5 ans il se sent pas dans le
tableau blanc ils sont terribles pour
alléger la charge et après midi je viens
trésor à 10
ans
est arrivé avec ces histoires là non
maintient une maison c'est là la seule
chose qu'on ferait pas dit son dernier
mot et ce en fait non non ce pâté les
chiens sauter
merci là là là même que je commence à
faire et on lire sur tekken 15 fois sa
carrière
il ya quand même le chien jamais sauté
pour lui il vient de sauter
ja ja données de la chaîne a voulu
surprendre
en direct la peau je ne sais pas quand
même j'aurais parce que là la santé dont
c'est un truc de fou a l'habitude on a
l'habitude bah oui c'est sûr nos
meilleurs ça juste en fait c'est c'est
simplement en fait ces enfants là existe
six enfants là sans la wii personnes la
nuit et on n'en tient pas ce genre de
vidéos quand ça n'existe pas quand c'est
un bibi lisez par les médias et par là
c'est là où ils se font tabasser c'est
là où ils se font assassiner mais c'est
là où ils se font détruire et à cause de
ça ils font ici ils se suicident ans de
suite alors elle a entendu les séries de
série d'accords la couture et des
massages du monde et là je dis tu revois
voilà oui à 56% un nom à la wii et wii
et wii et wii c'est un de ces personnes
et non mais oui oui 56% quoi ce qui nous
paraît toujours des bonnes raisons tout
cas le les chiffres sont là